the stock market rallied on wednesday
after the federal reserve announced it
will raise interest rates by 0.5 percent
this was widely anticipated by investors
as the central bank is combating surging
inflation
inflation is much too high and we
understand the hardship it is causing
and we're moving expeditiously to bring
it back down
by raising the interest rate it will be
more expensive for people businesses and
banks to borrow money as a result the
expectation is this will cool demands
for goods and services which will bring
prices down as well but this also comes
with the risk of triggering an economic
slowdown following the fed's
announcement the dow jones industrial
average went up over 300 points the s p
500 rose 1 and the nasdaq composite went
up 0.7
this comes after a rough april one of
the worst months on the market since the
onset of the pandemic in march 2020 and
one that saw the nasdaq's worst month
since 2008. this adjustment in the
interest rate is the largest one over
the last two decades signaling the fed
is taking rising inflation seriously
traders expect the fed to continue
raising interest rates in the next few
months current market expectations are
for the rate to hit 3 by the end of 2022
and while alarms over a recession are
not yet ringing loudly there is
recognition from analysts that the risk
of one occurring by 2023 is higher than
usual and that further market volatility
is to be expected
[Music]